When you've got it all working, then go
ahead and extend the code. Add a function greet
by period that takes the name and a period or a period's a time of day like
morning, afternoon, evening. And return a HelloClass object
whose greeting field includes a greeting using the name
and the period. For example, if the name is
the name is Kippy and the period is morning,
the message in the Hello Class would be: Good
morning Kippy! And if the name was Ken and
the period was evening, the message would be: Good
evening, Ken! Add this Endpoints API function to your app,
try it out in the API's explorer, and update
index with html to allow people to call this
function from the UI. So just to remind it
to go to the API Explorer. Go to /_ah/api/explorer and
when you've got your app working and it's got this new
function. This function must have this exact name because we're going
to test it and if you use a different name our
test won't work. Go ahead and enter your app id here